bonsoir samedi la chapelle qu'est ce que
vous donnez comme conseils aux étudiants
postsecondaires qui hante la ces jours
ci dans leur nouvelle vie mais vous
savez les étudiants peu importe domaine
qu'ils ont choisi auront tous un examen
en commun à la fin de la session ça
devrait on t'il bien géré leurs finances
dans cette nouvelle vie d'étudiant oui
pourquoi parce que bon quand on amorce
les études souvent il peut avoir
beaucoup d'argent dans le compte de
banque ont travaillé pendant l'été on
peut avoir reçu le versement des prêts
étudiants les bourses l'aide des parents
donc ça peut sembler que c'est beaucoup
d'argent mais ça ne donne pas de moyens
efficaces pour gérer ses liquidités loeb
après avoir des mauvaises surprises
d'ici la fin de l'année la fin de la
session donc évidemment au de jeu
discipliné au porteur discipline et se
doter d'outils et on veut un budget le
feu le budget c'est l'outil le plus
efficace donc identifie vraiment les
dépenses qu'on n'a pas le choix de payer
et identifier les dépenses
discrétionnaires qui sont sur lesquels
on a plus de maîtrise et de les faire à
partir de l'argent qu'on a réellement
donc il dément faire un budget c'est
relativement facile le suivre c'est au
quotidien parfois plus difficiles dont
on conseille aux étudiants de suivre les
dépenses conserver leurs factures s'ils
veulent faire une certaine comptabilité
à la semaine ou au mois de façon plus
manuels mais il ya aussi plusieurs
applications qui facilite énormément le
travail avec des liens avec vos comptes
de banque vos cartes de crédit que j'ai
trop parlé de carte de crédit est ce que
je bon d'avoir une carte de crédit ce
que c'est de là que c'est nécessaire
parce qu'il ya des bonnes dettes on
présume que prêts étudiants par exemple
c'est un endettement
acceptable c'est le meilleur choix au
niveau de l'endettement s'endetter pour
ses études c'est s'étonner
investissements donc c est tout à fait
correcte et une bonne dette le programme
officiel il est extraordinaire puisqu'il
permet de reporter évidemment le
remboursement à la fin des études
il permet aussi de déduire ses intérêts
de votre revenu imposable qui seraient
éventuellement plus important
des fonds par les chercheurs sont après
privée donc on ne vous d'un proche un
parent qui prennent prêté des sous si le
programme officiel et pas assez généreux
pour nos besoins et l'ultime recours
c'est les autres produits de financement
la carte de crédit toujours bon de se
rappeler donc oui on peut l'utiliser
pour de monter un bon dossier de crédit
avoir un écrin historique de crédit pour
nos futurs investissements immobiliers
mais il faut rembourser tous les mois le
seul dans notre carte de crime oui on a
sorti l'exemple quand on par exemple si
vous remboursez que 50 % du solde là il
ya des frères pays et puis seulement 5%
puis même seulement trois et demi pour
cent qui le paiement minimum ça peut
vous coûter très très cher on ferait
exactement donc la gare de crédit c'est
pour la consommation de base c'est pas
le moyen idéal pour financer des études
ya d'autres mécanismes à votre
disposition
vous êtes parent à la maison qu'est-ce
que qu'est ce qu'est ce que les parents
peuvent faire quelle est la meilleure
façon d'aider son enfant qui rentre au
cégep ou à l'université c'est ça que le
premier réflexe qu'on peut penser c est
ce que je peux aider financièrement mais
enfin ne vous dit peut-être pas l'unique
façon de bien les accompagner ses six
enfants qui commencent les études donc
soutenir financièrement c'est une chose
mais faut trouver un équilibre entre
diminuer les tracks up attaque financier
de nos enfants et leur faire prendre de
l'expérience comme comme gestionnaire de
leurs finances personnelles donc
différentes idées pour vous donc si vous
avez suffisamment de fonds dans le
régime enregistré d'épargne-études de
votre enfant au lieu de tout simplement
lui verser sans poser de questions
peut-être vous même développé un système
de prêts à long terme pour voir à quel
point votre bien gérer son argent qui
est allié aux contrôles oui mais quitte
à lui faire le cadeau à la fin des
études pour une mise de fonds
immobiliers ou partie son entreprise par
exemple si vous avez si vous voulez
quand même faire lui rendre un peu plus
la vie c'est plus facile vous pouvez
aussi lui donner mais vraiment
l'impliquer pas trop chouchoutés donc on
veut pas sûr protéger l'enfant on veut
l'impliquer dans le paiement des
factures la gestion de ses dépenses et
dans le fond lesté à être être prudent
dans la gestion de ses finances en
matière de travail où on a évoqué la
possibilité de travailler bien sûr on
peut travailler faut savoir si on paie
des impôts où on ne peut pas des impôts
ça dépend du montant qu'ils aient
déclaré le montant personnel de base oui
je puis les étudiants sont très en
demande donc les salaires sont en hausse
et que j'étais heureux je me suis posé
la question savoir si un étudiant elle
est vraiment le repousser des
opportunités de recettes alléchantes
pour des questions d'optimisation
fiscale mais si tel est le cas
en fait on peut garder en mémoire que
grosso modo à 15000 dollars de revenus
par année ont fait plus ou moins
d'impôts pour ce qui est du programme
d'aidé financière aux études c'est un
programme qui très personnalisable donc
dépend de votre situation individuelle
habitez vous chez vos parents et est-ce
que vous avez un conjoint ou non est ce
que vous avez des enfants pas de charge
est ce que vos études sont à temps
partiel à temps plein donc l'idéal c'est
vraiment d'aller faire une simulation
puis peut-être qu'on peut voir qu'à
partir d'un certain seuil de revenus
c'est plus intéressant se concentrent
aux études plutôt que de générer plus de
revenus de travail et c'est important de
faire sa déclaration de revenus parce
que des crédits disponibles il ya des
crédits disponibles et de toute façon on
a l'obligation dès qu'on a des revenus
d'emploi pour plus que 3500 $ de faire
des cotisations à la régie des rentes du
québec donc si on adapte des avantages à
le faire donc faire le calcul du crédit
pour seul rt au québec les cryptes pour
tps au fédéral aussi les frais de
scolarité donc en déclarant vos revenus
vous allez pouvoir les utiliser comme un
as pour un cri musique et non
remboursable si vous n'avez pas de
revenus pour il utiliser le crédit sera
reportée dans les années ultérieures
quand vous aurez intégrer le marché de
l'emploi des revenus plus importants
il ya aussi le revenu d'emploi que vous
vous avez même si ces cinq dix quinze
mille dollars par année contribuent à
créer des droits de cotisation reér que
vous avez utilisé dans le futur pour
pour déduire de votre revenu imposable
quand vous aurez enfin accéder à la
profession de vos rêves donc lévisien
vraiment ont le devoir de déclarer leurs
revenus et puis de toute façon ils vont
sûrement avoir un chèque au printemps
s'ils le font donc c'est un incitatif
puisque si l'on emploie y aurait il ya
des déductions à la source qui ont été
prises sur leur pays si les pousse à new
york chèque de remboursement donc ça
peut être un incitatif à conserver
toutes les pièces justificatives et les
factures de frais de collecte bon ben je
pense qu'ils sont prêts à rentrer à
l'école et à faire leur rentrée merci
samedi la chapelle pour ses conseils
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne i r d
[Musique]